un beau sapin pour avoir beaucoup de
cadeaux c'est la décoration essentiel de
noël avec des critères de choix très
précis bon sa part je le choisis en
fonction du volume de la hauteur et de
la verdure et n'ont pas tous le même
verre et donc je choisis un verre qui le
séduit par sa taille mais trop gros ni
trop petit chez l'horticulteur cédric
bouvier deux choix de sapins sont
possibles l'épicéa ou le nordman chacun
ses spécificités avec un prix plus élevé
pour ce dernier c'est qu un épicéa mais
moitié moins de temps à être cultivé cas
norman à norman d'un mètre cinquante un
médecin 15 faut compter entre 7 et 10
ans un épicéa en quatre ans vous en avez
un décoration d'intérieur il ya le point
ccja qui est très qui est très demandée
aux fêtes de fin d'année déjà d'une
passe qui fleurit à cette époque-ci et
en plus il a la couleur rouge rouge de
noël depuis quelques années on à la rose
de noël
l'hellébore qui est devenue une fleur
très importante pour les fêtes de fin
d'année est très en vogue couronnes de
l'avent petit sapin reconstituer
figurine du père noël cédric boully a
décidé de se diversifier dans les
produits vendus pour bien accompagner le
bo sa fin